so can able who missed three and a half
months for the last strain has been
really good since coming back and starts
today against this lineup for the mats
in game one of four
one gone first and here's jeff mcneil
swing and a miss on the curve ball two
up and two down for knable michael
conforto as one of those guys you were
talking about who
has a good track record and had a great
2020 but just has not been able to put
it together this year
popped up
who wants it
muncie with a call and the catch to
finish off escort his first inning for
corey knebel who does his job as the
opener taiwan walker who held the
dodgers hit list for the first six and a
third when he faced them last week gets
a second crack at him
so two up and two set aside is justin
turner having another fine year for la
eighth in the national league and on
base percentage first pitch swinging
flies went out to right conforto is
there and it's a seven pitch inning for
taiwan walker as he sets the dodgers
down one two three here's evan phillips
for his dodger debut
26 years old by the clayton north
carolina made one appearance for the
tampa bay rays and the dodgers claimed
him off waivers
phillips gets him two out
jonathan vr
switch hitter bats left-handed against
phillips
they pitch from phillips
slide to the left aj pollock is there
and evan phillips has a one two three
debut inning for the dodgers
so the dodgers have their first base
runner of the day against walker and
here's will smith
secret first with the lead off walk and
on a 1-2 smith punches one down the line
that is a fair ball into the corner
and to get it is conforto as seeger
stops it third on a smith double
so it is will smith to provide the first
hit against walker in both starts
aj pollock coming up 3-2 pitch
reaches out gets his bet on it to bring
home the game's first run
[Applause]
roy seeger scores productive out from aj
pollock and it's won nothing dodgers
dodgers on the board first taylor comes
up with smith now at third and the
infield pulled in halfway
grind through this it's q shot to first
smith comes home walker to the bag in
time but it's two nothing
on a pair of productive outs from
pollock and taylor
a man on for muncie
turner has two stolen bases as a dodger
23 this year tied for the national
league lead
and muncie takes a fastball for a strike
delayed steal attempt by turner and he
is off the bag and he's out
he was initially going to be safe but
the second base umpire marvin waited
marvin hudson waited to see that little
stumble he came off vr kept the tag on
him and they got the out on the delayed
steel attempt by turner
that is old-school delayed steel i
haven't seen that in a long time
and part of the reason it works is what
i was talking about before the
left-handed hitter when you don't get
the guy yelling he's going because he's
just bouncing off the bag
then you frame that ball you're still
blocked out by muncie and you can see he
got there ahead of it vr doing a good
job of react recognizing he was off and
then getting the tag back on it
so one out and one on metz are hitting
some balls hard now this last couple of
innings against evan phillips jd davis
grounded out his first time up
and he hits a rocket past the third
baseman turner down the left field line
that'll go to the corner alonzo on his
way to third he's going to be waved home
by gary destarcina
the throw to the plate will be too late
it's an rbi double for jd davis and the
mets are on the board
it's now 2-1 la
well they've been measuring
evan phillips for the last couple
innings he's got the best of them but
they're all on time on his fastball
right now jd davis you don't see him
pull
a good fastball very often you know that
means he was up there with a plan the
plan was to get the barrel out on the
fastball that's what he did
there him open the baseball hotbed of
cheyenne wyoming he's one for two he's
singled and bounced to third
on one two he hits it softly but he can
really run gonzalez
[Applause]
what a play
and you hope that he's all right
sprawling play here in his first
appearance off of the injured list
great play but obviously some concern
and hopefully he's okay
bellinger popped up his first time up
on one to bellman journey slaps one on
the ground vr has to make up space tough
throw for him and he's safe
bellinger gets down the line so quickly
terrific play by vr
vr did do a great job and makes an
accurate throw oh he got him he got it
yeah he got him and the mets are going
to challenge the call and they do make
the out call so the mets win the
challenge bellinger out at first
taylor takes third and two gone in the
inning for a pinch hitter so it's not
going to be baity instead billy mckinney
is going to come off the bat
slice the left center field towards the
gap mckinney with a pinch hit base hit
it brings home taylor mckinney flying
around second and holding with an rbi
double
great job by mckinney coming off the
bench
picking up the
two out rbi
talking about before the game the
dodgers yesterday versus the pittsburgh
pirates
scored nine runs six of those nine runs
came with two outs
there's a line up over for trey turner
eighth pitch to trey turner hit on the
ground through the right side he's done
it again with two strikes this time to
drive home billy mckinney and make it
4-1 dodgers
trey turner
complete hitter
bellinger's 0 for 2 vr made a tremendous
play to throw him out last time up
hillinger drives one deep toward the gap
in right center nimmo diving and he made
the catch
brandon with an outstanding play going
into the gap to rob bellinger of an
extra base hands like tryna comes onto
what is a save situation looking to pick
up his fourth this year mets are down to
their last out as dominic smith climbs
in
that's it
blake trying and carves them up in the
ninth and the dodgers win their seventh
straight by a final 4-1
on the offensive side
two out rbis they came up big
situational hitting guys at third base
less than two hours finding a way to get
them in but really the story the bullpen
once again outstanding each and every
one of those guys coming out of there
getting the job done